now ukrainian officials say that around
100 civilians still remain trapped at
the azov style steel mill in the
besieged city of mariupol despite
earlier reports that all civilians have
been evacuated well joining me now from
the steel plant is lieutenant ilya
samuelenko a commander with the
ukrainian armies as of regiment
lieutenant very good to talk to you tell
us
first of all
and tell the outside world about the
situation that you and your comrades are
facing right now
well hello everyone uh but first of all
uh i'm not a commander i'm just the
officer in the staff so that's for
notice uh one more thing um 100
civilians
been staying in as of style is mostly uh
uncheckable information yes we cannot
confirm it right now because a lot of
people can be under the crumble but so
far as we know as we know all the
civilians were evacuated but was what is
more important that uh who is also have
to be me requires evacuation is the
military garrison of the mario pole
because uh the count of uh injured and
our fallen
soldiers are very high and these people
deserve
all the proper care for proper cure
and
[Music]
and the rest at least uh nobody has been
expecting for uh for us to hold against
the russians for so long but still we're
fighting uh we're taking
heavy casualties we're taking losses uh
every day might be our last uh we have
extremely limited resources that are
very short
as for now
and
the result of this might be our imminent
death or capturing by the enemy which is
also means that for us
and the
consequences of these might be very i
mean extremely catastrophical for the
ukrainian defense in the ukrainian state
so
you see that's
somehow our call to the international
society is to help
help
to motivate your governments and our
governments to resolve this problem
quickly as as fast as possible
because there is no just the results
that people are dying right now our
lives means nothing
uh but our fight means everything and
the national security means everything
for us
uh mariupol is still under the siege and
under the enemy fire and the heavy fire
with the tanks bombs artillery rocket
artillery nothing changing for all these
75 days
maybe the intense intensity arise
differs day by day
but right now when the circle is like
tightening
uh we need immediate extraction or
evacuation no matter how it would be
made
we received the
uh incredible
united support from the world from the
people of the free world that we're
defending right now and from the
ukrainian people
but uh you know
any warm words any words of support and
any informational support will not stop
the bomb from collapsing your bunker
that may happen like in the next couple
of minutes or maybe one hour or maybe
tomorrow or nobody knows so yeah we were
fighting we were fighting very good
but our defensive capabilities and
fighting capabilities are like far
far lesser than we need right now
so uh actually
for military it's very complicated to
ask for the help yeah no we're not
asking for help we're asking for help or
to our government to let them
uh
make a good assistance for us
so what have you heard back from your
government presumably your government is
not helping you because it's it's not
able to break through the russian lines
uh it is able by the military way and
it's also able by the political way but
you know uh we can tell you how to do
this in a military way but uh of course
of course it will be the uh course of
the operation that where this will be
classified info but
uh
people who are sitting in the high
cabinets here in ukraine uh probably a
lot of them they basically uh understand
badly
the all the situation
the connection with the reality is
different it differs from our
perspective and the perception of the
reality uh the problem is that
the main problem is
what is our biggest concern
is the national security because
uh
in case of catastrophic consequences for
the variable garrison it will cause the
most catastrophic uh
consequences for the ukraine uh people
will people will
get through this yeah probably
after the russia's conqueror or
something like this
but uh what's what matters more that
i mean current governments uh they will
have like very very bad guys
um
but still still we are like trying to
support everyone here and like trying to
channelize the efforts here for the best
variants possible for best consequences
and lieutenant samolenko can i ask you
this
if the russians offered you terms of
surrender with safe passage would you
trust them would you surrender or do you
fight to the last
you see the problem is that my unit uh
is uh recognized in russia as a
terrorist organization
there will be no safe passage
it's it's a the very very interesting
thing because we already offered to
surrender yeah and we cannot surrender
because we do not have order to
surrender and we will not break our
previous order that's
that's incredibly important we're not
breaking orders we're making them we're
executing orders good very good
the problem is that uh we also the
witnesses of the russian war crimes here
in marvel where they like murdered more
than 25 000 people and they are not
interested in leaving us in keeping us
alive
and this is the third one thing yeah
it's just what i what i told you uh that
we are considered as a terrorist
organization in the in the russia
and every one of us can just can be
jailed
in up to like 25 to life
so
not very great day i'm thinking not
about my life my life means nothing like
like nothing means the life of the
people who have fallen here
uh my my friends my comrades like half
of my book list is uh half of my phone
book is like about collective obituary
but uh what i mean what matters a lot is
the ukrainian defense
uh and the national security and the
future of our people of our country
and that's that's that's why we are like
you know
uh trying to find other ways because our
capabilities to fight are far from
those that can be
that can affect right now
by the situation
lieutenant samuelenko it doesn't seem
enough to say best of luck to you but
our our thoughts
are with you thank you very much indeed
for joining us on sky news tonight
thank you so much for the time for your
time really appreciate this